[MUSIC PLAYING]
DR. HASLENDA HASHIM:
Industrial processes
are highly energy intensive,
and currently account
for one third of
global energy use.
CO2 emissions from
industries have increased
about 0.6% from 2012 to 2013.
This is equivalent to adding
27 million cars on the road.
How can industry
remain competitive
and commercially viable without
jeopardizing the environment?
One of the promising solutions
is the implementation
of industrial symbiosis.
In this teaching module, I'll
present an industrial symbiosis
case study In Nusajaya,
Iskandar Malaysia.
What is industrial symbiosis?
The concept of
industrial symbiosis
comes from natural ecosystems.
Let's take a look
at a simple example.
In nature, there is no
such thing as garbage.
Outputs becomes inputs
for a different part
of the ecosystem.
A falling leaf decomposes
into soil nutrients
when then allows tree to grow.
In other words, waste
has become resource,
and the process is repeated
in a closed ecological system.
The same principle is applied
in industrial symbiosis.
Industrial symbiosis is
an innovative concept
where the byproduct, or
output, of one company
can become the raw
material of another company
by creating a closed
cycle of waste
resources between companies.
It involves exchanges
of byproduct and energy
between companies.
More than 170 successful
industrial symbioses
can be found in the world,
such as Kalundborg Symbiosis
Park in Denmark, Kawasaki
Eco Industrial Park in Japan,
Smart Park in Texas,
USA, Ulsan in Korea,
[INAUDIBLE] Industrial
Park in China,
and Green Industrial
Park in Nusajaya.
In Malaysia,
industrial symbiosis
is put into practice
in Iskandar Malaysia,
located in southern
peninsula Malaysia,
in a complex known as
the Southern Industrial
and Logistics Cluster
located in Nusajaya.
Industrial symbiosis
in Nusajaya is
built as a network
of cooperation
between four biotech companies.
The companies exchange
materials, byproduct,
or energy with each other.
For example, one utility
company [INAUDIBLE]
is using palm oil waste as fuel
to give its steam steady supply
to nearby industries.
Industrial waste generated
from other companies
will also be sent to
[INAUDIBLE] treatment facilities
for further processing, to
produce an alternative fuel
called bio-gas.
The bio-gas generator can then
be used as a renewable energy
source to generate steam or
electricity to supply back
to the industrial area nearby.
The waste left after
this process is then
sold as fertilizer.
AS you can see, the
visualization clearly shows
the main concept of
industrial symbiosis,
which is utilization of one
company byproduct, energy,
or what is raw material
for another company
has been implemented
in Nusajaya.
How can industrial
symbiosis reduce emissions,
and generate economic benefits?
Or, in other words,
what is the advantages
of industrial symbiosis.
There are multiple advantages
industrial symbiosis.
First, the practice
significantly
reduces the volume of waste
being disposed in landfills.
Second, the cost of raw material
and waste treatment is reduced.
Third, raw material,
energy, and water
are conserved, because
the byproduct always
are turned into raw material,
energy is recovered,
and what there is used.
Fourth, industrial
symbiosis also
leads to reduction in fuel
consumption and transportation
costs, due to shortened
transportation distances
for byproduct or
waste to the industry.
As a result,
industrial symbiosis
could produce fewer
transportation-related
emissions.
An sample of successful
industrial symbiosis
is Kalundborg It is the world's
first industrial symbiosis
site, and has been in operation
for more than 30 years.
It has achieved significant
environmental and economic
returns.
Through integrating
30 companies,
Kalundborg has reduced about
160,000 tons of CO2 emissions,
and saved 3 million
meters cubed of water.
The process also saved more than
$1 million US dollar annually,
all due to recycling and reuse
of industrial byproducts.
in comparison, industrial
symbiosis in Nusajaya
has only been
operating since 2009,
and is still at
its infant stage.
However, given the
benefit at Kalundborg,
industrial symbiosis in
Nusajaya in the long run
could be a very
promising strategy
to help reduce carbon emissions
by 50% in the Iskandar region
by 2025.
This is in line with the action
plans in the low carbon society
blueprint for Iskandar Malaysia.
As we all know,
our prime minister
was launched low carbons
blueprints in 2012.
So could you please explain,
what is the insight low carbon
society blueprint for
Iskandar Malaysia.
SPEAKER: I believe
we are talking
about this blueprint, the low
carbon society blueprint, that
actually give the 12
action framework for how
Iskandar nation should drive.
And it actually cover our three
main core component, economy,
[INAUDIBLE] and
also environment.
And this 12 actions
plan is actually
looking at how each of us
can actually working together
to actually drive this
initiative in Iskandar
Malaysia.
DR. HASLENDA HASHIM:
Successful implementation
of industrial symbiosis
will not happen by accident.
Several challenges
need to be overcome
for the development of
industrial symbiosis
in Nusajaya to become
a successful model.
First issue is related
to logistic factor.
There are four palm oil mills
within 20 to 40 kilometers
in Iskandar Malaysia.
These mills are a
potential supply of waste
to the industrial park.
This long distance however
will require large storage
in industrial park to ensure the
continuous supply of palm oil
waste.
Thus, it is recommended to site
industrial symbiosis in an area
adjacent or close to the source
of waste, such as palm oil
mills, to minimize the
cost of transportation,
as well as reduce
the size of storage
needed for palm oil waste.
Second, a major challenge
concerns laws and regulations.
The national green technology
policy and feed-in tariffs
were established
in 2009 and 2011
to promote sustainable
development for industry
in Malaysia.
However, there are no specific
regulations or policies
to encourage industry to
form symbiotic linkages.
in Japan, for example, the
sound material cycle society
was formed.
It consists of various recycling
and green purchasing laws
to support the creating
and selling of waste
for industry inside and
outside the industrial park.
This initiative will create
sufficient and comparatively
cheaper waste to use as
raw material for industry.
In addition to the lack
of appropriate policy,
lack of financial
support is also
one of the barriers that
hinder the development
of a more complex industrial
symbiosis park in Nusajaya.
In Japan, for example,
227 million US dollar
were allocated by the government
to build new recycling plants
in Kawasaki Eco-Town in 1997.
In Malaysia, the sustainable
energy development authority
provides financial incentive
in the form of feed-in tariffs.
However, these incentive are
only beneficial for palm oil
industry park because
they have no cost
for waste or transportation.
In addition to the factors
that I have just highlighted,
the concept of industrial
symbiosis in Nusajaya
can be extended to urban
symbiosis similar to the system
in Kalundborg.
Special planning
factor, which is
the distance between industrial
park and residential area,
and strong linkages between
state and local government,
have contributed to
this integrated effort.
The sustainable
supply of waste could
be generated from this effort,
since municipal waste could
also become a source off
raw material for industry.
In return, the municipality also
benefits from this initiative.
Since the energy generated
by industrial symbiosis
will be supplied to
the municipality,
thus reducing the municipality
heavy reliance on fossil fuel.
What can be learned from
industrial symbiosis
in Nusajaya?
And how can it be
duplicated elsewhere?
The case of industrial
symbiosis in Nusajaya
provides a good
lesson to accelerate
the development of
industrial symbiosis
in developing countries.
The primary elements that
are necessary to support
the successful implementation
of industrial symbiosis
in other countries are,
first, availability
of renewable energy source.
Second, distance from the
renewable energy source
to the industrial park.
Third, a strong regulatory
and legal structure
around climate
change mitigations.
Fourth, financial incentives.
Fifth, strong linkages
between national, state,
and local development
to encourage
integrated industrial
and urban symbiosis.
Last but not least,
this initiative
would not be possible
without strong commitment
from industry and stakeholders
to its sustainable development.
As we come to the
end, can industry
save the environment while
also remaining competitive?
The answer is simple.
Turning waste to
resources by implementing
industrial symbiosis.